in the years after the collapse the  world had no Guardians  it had only iron Lords immortal fearless  we fought to protect the survivors of a  once great age our battle was about more  than crawling back from the shadows the  iron Lords would give humanity back its  future  [Music]  some know the legend but no one truly  knows how the iron Lords died their  final deaths that was something you had  to be there for to witness to remember  to know even heroes can die and survival  is not always a victory  now I am the lone sentry and my watch is  eternal waiting for the day when  whatever we disturbed awakens  [Music]  the iron Lords are gone but our fight is  far from over  [Music]